The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AMARTYA SHANKHA
BISWAS: So today, we're
going to look at approximation
algorithms for the traveling
salesman problem.
So I hope everyone knows
what the traveling salesman
problem is.
You have a graph, you're
trying to visit every vertex.
So you start at your vertex,
you visit every single one,
and you end at the
starting vertex.
And you want to do that in
the shortest possible time,
or distance, or
whatever the metric is.
So, unfortunately,
this is NP-hard.
Also, the approximation
algorithms
for any constant approximation
is also known to be NP-hard.
So you should have gone over
approximation algorithms
in lectures.
So, basically, let's say
the optimal solution has
some value of e, and if
you want to guarantee
that your algorithm will
end up with a value which
is within a constant factor
of v, so less than cv,
that is an
approximation algorithm.
But for the traveling
salesman problem,
the constant approximation
algorithms are also NP-hard.
So instead, we
modify it slightly.
So, on the traveling
salesman problem,
we impose something
called a metric.
So the important relation
here is this one.
So, first of all,
let's go through this.
So you have a
distance metric for--
so xy are vertices.
Your distance is always greater
than 0, which is reasonable.
You're undirected,
which is this relation.
And you have the
triangle inequality,
which means that if
you have 3 vertices,
and you have distance like
this, this distance is always
smaller than the sum of
these two distances, which
is like real world-ish things
that make sense, right?
If this distance was
longer, it would just
take this path instead.
So the distance by
taking other node
is always greater than or
equal to the direct distance.
So, turns out, the Metric
TSP problem is also NP-hard.
So nothing very
great there, but you
can do a constant
approximation here.
And you'll go through
two approximations today.
The first, the simpler
one, is a 2 approximation,
and then, we'll
improve this to 3/2.
So let's start
with the first one.
So before we begin, let's
define a couple of terms.
Let's define c of
S. So what is S?
Let X be a path.
Or, rather, let's say
S is a set of edges.
So if you have your graph,
here, your set of edges
could be something like
this, this, this, this.
So that's set of edges.
And c of S is defined as the
sum of the weights of all
the edges.
And this, actually,
should be a multiset,
because you can count
the same edge twice.
So you can count this
edge three times, or how
ever many times you want.
So that's the definition.
So, now, we want to
find a cycle which
goes through all
the vertices, and we
want to minimize the
cost of that cycle.
So let's say your optimal--
this should remind you of the
Hamiltonian Cycle problem.
So this is, essentially,
finding a Hamiltonian cycle
in the graph of minimum weight.
So this is worse than the
Hamiltonian cycle problem.
This is find the minimum
weight Hamiltonian cycle.
So let's say there exists this
beautiful Hamiltonian cycle.
You know of minimum weight.
Let's call that
H star G. So it's
the best Hamiltonian
cycle on this graph,
and that's the shortest path
that your traveling salesman
can take.
And so the cost of that is
given by C if H star S G.
So how do we go about trying
to approximate this problem?
So think about what
algorithms you've
seen that sort of connect
all the vertices of a graph,
and minimize costs of edges.
Does it remind you of
anything polynomial
that you've seen in the class,
that connects all the vertices?
Expands all the vertices?
Exactly.
So Kruskal, minimum
spanning tree.
This minimum spanning
tree is polynomial time,
and it connects all the vertex.
So let's take some graph.
Let's just go with this one.
So you have some vertices,
and you make a minimum
spanning tree out of them.
Now, clearly, this
is not a cycle yet.
But let's try to
construct a path out
of this minimum spanning tree.
So, first, let's root it.
So let's say we are rooted
minimum spanning tree.
Let's say this is the root.
So you have three things
going out of there.
I think that's it.
So let's give these labels.
So, now, what we're
going to do is,
the way we're going to
traverse all the vertices,
let's just do a DFS.
So, in DFS traversal,
you'll first
see 1, then you'll
go down and see 2,
then you'll go down and see
3, then you'll go back up,
see 2 again.
Go back down, see 4.
Go back up, see 2.
1, 5, 1, 6.
So, basically, you're ignoring
the rest of the graph.
You find your minimum
spanning tree,
and you follow all the paths.
Follow them back up, and
just do a DFS traversal.
And then, you go
reach back to 1.
And then, you have this--
well, it visits
all the vertices.
It visits some of
them more than once,
which is a problem, which
we'll deal with shortly.
But it visits all the
vertices, and it's a cycle.
So, now, the problem is,
the traveling salesman
problem does not allow you to
visit vertices more than once.
Because, if you did not
have this restriction,
you could shorten
your bat length
by going to a separate
vertex and coming back,
or something like that.
So let's make that
more concrete.
So, at least in this case,
given this triangle inequality,
I claim that you can just
delete the duplicate vertices.
So let's look at
the duplicate ones.
You have 1, 2, 3, this repeats.
So you delete that.
Repeats, repeats, repeats,
and that's cycling back.
So how do you delete things?
So, in this case, you
had a path, right?
You were going 1 to 2, and
2 to 3, to 2, and so on.
Let's write the 4 in.
So this is [INAUDIBLE]
only at tree edges.
So how would you delete this?
So, let's say, you find
the first duplicate vertex,
and you don't want that.
That's not allowed.
So all you do is, simply,
you follow the path,
and you bypass it.
And by the triangle inequality,
you know that bypassing it
will never increase your cost.
It'll decrease it, or it
will keep it the same.
So you can remove the
duplicate vertex in this path
just by bypassing it.
But, also, remember that
this is a complete graph.
So the metric is defined
on all pairs of vertices.
So every edge exists
with some value.
So that also follows with
the triangle inequality.
So if an edge does not exist,
just make it the sum of the--
so if xz is not an edge, just
make it the sum of xy plus yz.
So in any case, you construct
the initial path just
by going down the tree and
doing a naive DFS traversal.
And, then, you correct
that path by skipping
over the duplicates.
So, finally, we'll end
up with [INAUDIBLE]
skipping all the duplicates
we'll get a 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
1.
And that's a valid cycle.
So let's call this
minimum spanning tree
T. So that's your MST.
And you are removing duplicate
edges, and getting a cycle, C.
So now, actually, let's
take another step back.
OK, let's define
our cycle, first.
So let's call this
cycle, this guy
is C. And then,
you're going from C,
and you're deleting
the duplicates,
and you're getting C dash.
So now what you have
is cost of C dash.
That's a [INAUDIBLE],,
but anyway.
The cost of C dash is less
than equal to cost of C.
And what is the cost of C?
If you know the weight of
your minimum spanning tree,
what is the cost of C?
C is just doing a DFS traversal.
So what is the cost
of C, if you know
your minimum spanning tree?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS: No.
So you're traversing every edge
in the minimum spanning tree
twice.
So you're doing a
DFS traversal, right?
So you're going down, and
you're coming back up.
So you're going down, coming
back up, backtracking,
coming back down.
So every edge is
traversed, right?
So it's exactly twice T.
So let's bring up
a different board.
So you know that
cost of C is twice
the cost of T. Does
that make sense,
why the traversal implies
that you have every edge being
visited twice, right?
OK.
So, now, our claim is that the C
dash cycle is a 2 approximation
of the actual cycle.
So why is that?
So we've already proves, so this
also implies that C of C dash
is less than equal
to 2 of C T. Realize
that this is not a valid cycle,
but this is a valid cycle.
So, now, we need to show
that this is somehow
bounded by a star G.
So how do you do that?
Well, look at H star
G. What is H star G?
H star G is just a cycle, which
goes through the optimal cycle,
which goes through
all the vertices
and comes back to
the parent vertex.
So this is H star of G.
This is the optimal thing.
Now, you can take an edge,
e, here, and delete it.
And then you'll get
a spanning tree,
because this is
your optimal cycle.
Remove one edge, and
you get a spanning tree.
So let's call that T dash.
Does that make sense, why
that is a spanning tree?
Because you had a cycle,
and you remove one edge,
so it touches all the
vertices, and it's a tree.
So it's a spanning
tree, but it's not
the minimum spanning tree.
So you know that H star G,
the cost of H star of G,
is greater than equal
to the cost of H
star of G minus the
edge we removed,
is greater than equal to
the cost of T. Make sense?
So you remove one
edge, and then that
is still greater than the
minimum spanning tree.
So, now, combining
this guy and this guy,
you get cost of C dash is less
than equal to 2 [INAUDIBLE]..
We know that cost of C is
less than cost of H of G,
so you get a 2-approximation.
So does that make sense?
So that was a 2-approximation.
That was pretty
straightforward, We just
constructed a spanning tree.
You did a DFS traversal
and removed duplicates,
and you have a nice path.
OK, let's just keep it down.
But here's the thing.
It seems kind of wasteful
to go through all the edges
when you don't need to.
So you're traveling down the
tree, you're going back up,
and you're traversing
every edge twice.
So it seems kind of
ridiculous that you would
be doing every edge twice.
So what could you do better?
Well, before we introduce that,
let's prove a couple of lemmas.
So, first, we started with this.
So let's say S is a subset
of V. So you have a graph,
and you make a subgraph.
So you pick out some vertices.
So you pick out this one,
and this one, and this one,
and this one, and
that is your S.
And, so, you get
a new graph which
contains just those vertices.
And, whatever, I
just connect them.
So the claim is
that that graph also
has a Hamiltonian cycle,
the minimum cost Hamiltonian
cycle, which is also the
traveling salesman solution.
So let's call that H star of
S. So it's some cycle, which
looks like this, I guess, here.
So H star of S. Now, the claim
is that the cost of H star of S
is less than equal to
the cost of H star of G.
That should make
intuitive sense,
because you're taking
only some of the vertices
and trying to traverse
them, and, in this case,
you'll try to traverse
all the vertices.
However, this is only true
because of the triangle
inequality, and let's
see why that is the case.
So, proof by contradiction.
Say cost of H star of
S is actually greater
than cost of H star of G.
OK, so, look at H star of G.
It's a cycle, right?
So you have something.
Your cycle.
And, in this cycle, you
have all the vertices of S.
So pick them out.
And, now, you have
a cycle which has
cost less than the
optimal cycle in S,
but it contains all the vertices
in S. So what you can do
is, now you can use the
skipping lemma from before.
So, last time, we didn't
move duplicate vertices.
But, this time, what you'll
do is, instead, you'll
just skip over this vertex.
We'll skip over this vertex.
And so, every vertex that's
not an S, skip over it.
And that can only
decrease the cost.
So, now, you've constructed
another cycle, which
contains only the
vertices of S. So it's
a Hamiltonian cycle for S, but
it has cost less than equal
to H star of G, which means
that this can never be true.
So the important fact
is, there, that if you
have a subset of vertices
making the restricted graph,
the cost of the minimum
Hamiltonian cycle
is always less than equal to
the one in the original graph.
So, intuitively, that
should make sense.
OK, next thing is
something which
might seem unfamiliar right
now, perfect matchings.
So you've seen perfect
matchings in the content
of bipartite graphs, right?
So you find the minimum
cost perfect matching.
You do this flow thing,
you send all the flow in,
and then you connect the
vertices with the capacities,
and whatever.
So, it turns out,
in a complete graph,
you can still do
perfect matching.
So perfect matching is,
you have a bunch of--
so, let's say, you need to have
an even number of vertices,
right, until we have
perfect matching.
So, let's say, you
have these varieties.
So this is a perfect matching.
So every vertex has one edge
coming out of it, exactly one
edge coming out of it.
And it needs to be even,
because, otherwise, that
doesn't work out.
So that's perfect matching,
and the minimum cost
perfect matching is the
minimum among all such things.
And you did this for
bivariate graphs.
It's finite
[INAUDIBLE] networks.
So I'm not going to go into
the algorithm for this.
It's kind of complicated, but
it uses linear programming,
and you can find this
for a complete graph,
and it's polynomial,
so that's good.
So, given a complete graph, you
can find the perfect matching.
[INAUDIBLE] for now.
OK, one last thing we want to
introduce is Euler circuits.
So who has heard of
Euler circuits before?
Anyone?
Sort of?
OK.
So the reason we are--
so, OK, let's go back
to what we did before.
We had a tree, and the best
way we found to traverse it
was just going down, and
going back up, and going down,
and terribly messy.
So what we would,
rather, want to do,
is sort of traverse the thing
without repeating edges.
So, I don't know,
you've probably
seen this puzzle before.
So you have this
graph given to you,
and the task is to draw
this graph without lifting
your pen off the paper.
So first, for example,
in this graph,
you could start here,
go here, go here,
and come back, and
something, and there you got.
So you can do that.
But if you add on another
lobe, here, then you
can't make a circuit.
You can still make
a path, I believe.
If you add another one,
you can't even make a path.
So how does this work?
Let's see.
So, let's say, forget
about the graph, for now.
Let's say you're just drawing.
So you start somewhere.
You go to a vertex.
You go to another vertex.
Come back, go to this
vertex, leave it.
And so, observe that, whenever
you're making this drawing,
you go to a vertex,
and you leave it.
Every time you hit a
vertex, you leave it.
Since there's the circuit,
you just loop around,
and every time you
enter a vertex,
you'll have to leave it.
What that means is that,
even though this is not
directed, if you drew out the
actual path, you would see,
the number of edges
going into a vertex
is equal the number
of ones leaving,
which means that every
degree has to be even.
So if you go and look at this
graph, which is that of lobes,
this degree is not even.
Neither is this, neither
is this, neither is this.
They're all 5, I think, yeah.
They're all 5, which
means that this can never
have an Euler circuit.
So a graph can only
have an Euler circuit
if it has even degrees
for every vertex.
And the other way is also true.
If a graph has even
degrees on every vertex,
then it must have
an Euler circuit.
That's not hard to
prove, but there's
a constructive
algorithm you can use.
So, let's say, you're given
this graph, for instance.
You would simply
go to the graph,
just start at some random
node, and then go through,
and keep following
edges until you
can no longer following edges.
So, let's say, you stop here.
Then, you pick another
edge, and start, and so on.
And, then, you can splice these
cycles together at some point.
So it's kind of a
[INAUDIBLE] argument,
but it should be
sort of intuitive
why you can construct another
path, given an even degree.
You just perform searches.
You just create cycles, and
you splice them together.
But, for now, just
take it as fact
that a graph is
an Euler circuit,
as in you can draw it
without lifting your pen off,
if, and only if, every
vertex has even degree,
so why is that interesting?
So, let's say, we could
add some edges to our tree
and turn it into one
of those nice graphs.
Right now, this is not, right?
This is degree 1, degree 1,
degree 3, degree 1, degree 1,
degree 3.
All of them are odd,
so that's not good.
But, let's say, you could
add some edges in, turn it
into an Euler
circuit, and then you
could do a nice reversal off it,
and, maybe, that will give you
a better approximation.
So with that hope, let's
look at the algorithm.
So what you do is, you
go back to your tree.
Let's just leave it at that.
So, now, let's see.
So this is degree
2, that's good.
This is degree 3,
that's not good.
Degree 1, this is fine.
This is degree 1.
This also is degree 1.
This is degree 3.
Actually, let's get rid of this,
so it does not have degree 3.
That's a lot of vertices.
OK, there we go.
So, in this graph,
you see that you
have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 vertices
which have degree odd.
So, now, we would like to
add some edges to turn this
into an Euler circuitable graph.
So how do we do that?
So let's call the set of odd
edges S. Odd vertices, sorry.
So you take the set of
odd-degree vertices.
Now, go back to
perfect matchings.
So what does a
perfect matching do?
It adds edges to that
graph so that everything
gets degree increased by one.
So if you increase the degree
of all the odd vertices by 1,
everything turns even, right?
So you take the set
of odd vertices.
OK, another thing to observe.
Realize that, how many
odd vertices can you have?
Can you have an odd
number of odd vertices?
Because that would screw
up the whole thing where we
needed an even number of things.
So why is that not possible?
Why can you not have an
odd number of odd vertices?
So the thing is, that, let's
say, you have some graph,
and what is the sum of
the degrees of the graph?
Let's move to a
different board for this.
So you have a graph, G, and
you want sum of degrees.
So di is the degree, for all
V. So what is this equal to?
So, let's say, you
have this graph.
So, now, if you count the
degrees of every vertex,
you're basically counting the
number of edges coming out,
which means that every
edge is counted twice, once
for this end point and
once for this end point.
So this edge is counted
twice, for here and here.
This edge is also counted twice.
So, basically, the
sum of the degrees
is nothing but 2 times mod
of E. Does that make sense?
So this is even.
Now, let's say you take
only the odd vertices out.
So the even vertices are good.
This is good.
This is not good.
This is also not good.
So these are the odd vertices.
So the sum of the degrees
of the even vertices
are, by definition, even.
So, if you remove them,
the sum of the odd vertices
should also remain even.
And so, you have the sum of
odd degrees becoming even,
which means that you'll need
to have an even number of them.
Make sense?
So, going back to this, so
there's a lot of branching off,
here.
But going back to
the main point,
here, is that you have an
even number of odd vertices.
So consider the restriction
of the original graph,
G to this set, S.
So, now, we're going
to the first thing
we did, there,
where we considered a
restriction of the graph
to a certain set of vertices.
So we take the set,
so 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So you take these five vertices.
And you consider the graph that
is restricted to these five
vertices.
Oh, sorry, there should be six.
Oh, that's interesting.
Oh, there we go.
That's the other one.
So those are the six vertices
which have odd degrees.
Now, you find the
perfect matching
with your polynomial-time
algorithm,
and you get something.
So you can now add those
edges back in here.
So these are your new
edges, and, let's say,
something, this one.
OK, so you get three new edges.
And, now, realize that all
the degrees are now even,
so now you can do
your Euler circuit.
Also, let's call this matching
M. So this is a set of edges,
M. Let's call the
original tree T,
and the new thing that
is formed, is T union M.
So you're taking all
the edges from T,
and you're adding
all the edges from M.
So, realize that you
can have multiple edges,
but that's fine, because
Euler circuits allow
you to have multiple edges.
So, now, you take
this graph, and you
find this Euler circuit.
So that is basically this thing.
So this set of edges in some
order, and that order exists.
So the cost of the
Euler circuit--
let's call it C--
is equal to the cost of T
plus the cost of M, right?
Because you're traversing
all the edges in your graph.
So that is the cost
for the Euler circuit.
Now, my claim is that--
so this is the difference
between all the nodes
in the graph.
And, remember, you can do the
whole duplication argument,
from before.
So, where's that?
Oh, there.
So you can do a
duplication argument,
so you're visiting all
the edges in the graph,
all the vertices in the graph.
You remove the duplicates,
and you have a valid path.
Now, let's see if this
valid path is actually
a better approximation.
So, again, you will go
from C. So this C, you
will go to C dash.
And this will give you,
as before, cost of C dash
is less than equal
to the cost of C,
So, now, you're only
interested in cost of C.
So what are we doing there?
So we know that the cost
of C is equal to cost
of T plus the cost of M. So,
from the previous problem,
we know that the cost of T is
less than equal to the cost
of H star of G, right?
So this is less than
equal to cost of H star G.
So this guy is less than the
optimal Hamiltonian path.
What about this guy?
So let's look at the
actual H star G, again.
So, actually, let's
look at H star S.
So remember that S is
the set of odd vertices,
and that is where
this matching is done.
So H star S is nothing but
the optimal Hamiltonian
cycle on that restricted graph.
From our previous lemma,
which is down here,
we know that H star of S
is less than H star of G.
So we know that cost of is less
than equal to cost of whatever,
G. So, now, let's just
look at H star of S. Now,
we construct a matching.
We take every other edge.
We take this one, and we take
this one, and we take this one.
And look at the
alternate set, also.
So take this one, and
this one, and this one.
So look at the blue
set and the red set.
Since it's part of
a Hamiltonian cycle,
they're both matchings, right?
So let's call the red one
M1, and the blue one M2.
So I'm not saying they're
perfect matchings.
They're not the
minimum matchings,
but they're definitely
perfect matchings.
And because we know the
perfect matching is M,
or the minimum matching
is M. Cost of M
is less than equal to cost of
M1, and, also, the cost of M
is less than equal
to the cost of M2.
That make sense?
Because M was the
minimum cost matching,
you have cost of M is less
than any other matching, which
is constructed from this.
Again, so this implies
that the cost of M
is less than equal
to half cost of--
OK, let's not write this here.
Let's get a different board.
So cost of n is less than
equal to half cost of M1
plus cost of M2.
Since both of these guys
are larger than this,
their average is also
larger than this, right?
But what is cost
of M1 cost of M2?
This is nothing but half
cost of H star of S, right?
Because the Hamiltonian cycle
is constructed from M1 and M2.
And by our lemma,
this is less than
equal to half cost
of H star of G.
So, now, we have all we need.
This is less than equal to
half cost of H star of G.
And then, add them together,
you get cost of C dash
is less than equal to
cost of C, is less than
equal to the sum, which is equal
to 3/2 cost of H star of G.
So that's the proof.
So there's a lot of
things going on, here.
Let's try to go back
and see what we did.
So we took a minimum
spanning tree,
and then we tried to remove
all the odd degree vertices.
So we took all the
odd degree vertices,
and made a perfect matching, the
minimum cost perfect matching.
So we added edges just to
make everything even degree.
Then, we took the Euler
circuit on that graph,
and we removed duplicates.
So that's fine,
that's the easy part.
But you do [INAUDIBLE]
circuit on that graph,
then you argued that, because
all the circuits in that graph
is just the sum of the
edges in the spanning tree
plus the sum of the edges
in the matching, which
you added later.
So the spanning tree
had already bounded,
in the previous argument.
The matching was bounded by
taking the optimal Hamiltonian
cycle, decomposing it
into two matchings,
arguing that those two matchings
are not the optimal matchings--
not necessarily the
optimal matchings,
but they're less than
equal to the optimal.
So they're even, there.
And, so, the cost of
the optimal matching,
which you were using in
our constructive path,
constructive
Hamiltonian cycle, is
less than equal to
both of these matching.
You add them up, you get
that bound, and it works.
So questions on
any of the steps?
This is a lot of branching off
and then coming back together.
Yeah.
STUDENT: The last
one's 3/2, right?
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS: Yes.
That is not 3 over 3.
That would be p equal to np.
Anything else?
You're free to go, or ask
questions, or whatever.